فمعيه الان مباشره من عمان الاستاذ عامر
الشوبكيه الباحث الاقتصاديه المتخصص في
شؤون النفط والطاقه اهلا ومرحبا بك على
الرئاسه الروسيه حذرت اليوم من زعزعت
استقرار سوق الطاقه العالميه كما قالت بعد
بدء سريان هذا الحد الاقصى الذي فرضته
مجموعه السبعه على السعر النفط الروسي
برايك ما هي تداعيات هذا القرار على سوق
الطاقه العالميه
التفضيل مصالحها السياسيه على مصالحها
الاقتصاديه وبالتالي ستضر نفسك اذا ما
قررت حجب اكبر مورد
للخزانه الروسيه وبالتالي همم هذا ايضا
همم يتبعه اخرى بعدم قدره روسيا على
السعاده اذا ما قررت تخفيض انتاجها بالفعل
لكن هذا الامر يبقى وارد
ولذلك ايضا يوجد بعض الاو بيد روسيا منها
قطع الغاز بشكل كامل عن اوروبا ما زال غاز
الروسي يتدفق الى اوروبا من الخط المرعبرو
اوكرانيا وخط ترك ستريم
ويشكل سبعه ونص من الحاجه الاوروبيه للغاز
وهي ضروريه لمرور اوروبا من فصل الشتاء
الحالي
اعتقد بان ايضا ال 60 دولار المحدده للسقف
سعر النفط الروسي لبرميل النفط الروسي
ايضا تلبي الموازنه الروسيه ولن تنتظر
كثيرا ولن تؤثر كثيرا على ارادات روسيا
خاصه وان هذا الشعر ايضا قريبا من
التخفيضات التي تمنحها روسيا لدول صديقه
مثل الهند والصين وبامكان روسيا توجيه
معظم ان النفط الذي كان يذهب الى اوروبا
الى القاره الاسيويه وعملاء اخرين اهمهم
تركيا والهند والصين نعم
طيب ايه استاذ عامر الشوبكي يعني الى اي
حد يمكن القول بان هذا القرار وبدا ريان
هذا الحد الاقصى الذي تفرضوا مجموعه
السبعه لسعر النفط الروسي قد يؤدي الى وقف
يعني تدفق ملايين البراميل من السوق
العالميه
اليوم على الاسعار بشكل ضعيف جدا 2% او
اثنين دولار فقط البرميل ارتفع اليوم مع
بدء سريان العقوبات والحظر الاوربي على
النفط الروسي وهي يعني ضربه قويهتين الى
اسواق النفط العالميه ومع ذلك السقوف
الشعريه كان الهدف منها تقليس اي ارتفاع
لاسعار النفط المتزامل مع الحظر الاوربي
على النفط الروسي ولذلك راينا الاسعار لم
ترتفع بشكل كبير وهدات واعتقد بانها
ستنخفض لكن الضرب الكبرى ستكون
للاسعار
والاقتصاد الروسي وربما يكون لها تاثير
ايضا على اوروبا الحظر المنتظر على
المشتقات النفسيه المقرره من روسيا الديزل
ياتي 60% من حاجه اوروبا من روسيا
وبالتالي حضروا في الخامس من فبراير
القادم سيكون مؤثر بشكل اكبر اعتقد حتى من
الحضر الحالي على النفط الرو والشقوق
الشعريه
ابسط عمر شو بك يا البحر الاقتصادي
المتخصص في شؤون النفط وانطاقه شكرا لك
على كل هذه التفاصيل وانت معنا مباشره من
عمان